home
go up here call it a fight mode when
you're in middle of a fight you need to
have all your adrenaline on the maximum
you drive and when you have White's
attacking you from all sides you're not
super maximum to build you've got to
loosen up you've got to be ready for a
fight and it needs some screaming you
need some hitting the acts even the
actors are so in turn and she does
arrive just in the nick of time which is
you just have to there's no other way
that this scene could be written
one of the main dramatic events of this
is the course the Dragons coming to the
rescue and they're north of the wall and
so you get the direct you know explosion
of fire against ice which is the central
sort of motif of this whole story saga
this is like a cutting torch you know
going into piece of ice imagine if
you've dumped water into a blazing hot
pot it explodes
[Music]
I think back now there was not a script
when I smoked it even damn the first
time of it coming back to the season but
they told me the story and then when
they told me you know the details of the
final scene and this was always the
episode that was in some ways we're most
excited about and also the most nervous
about because so much but it's dependent
on those you know the final cepheus
actually working
the eyes of the white walkers and the
whites have been such a prominent
feature of the show and a lot of work
has gone into the specifics of how the
eyes look and to see that hopefully
iconic image at this point blown up to
the size of you know a beach ball that
seemed like it was in crowd-pleasing Lee
oh [ __ ] moment
hey everybody this is my new Game of
Thrones Q&A but they also dropped this
behind-the-scenes documentary for
episode six right before I was getting
ready to make it so I just wanted to
take some of the best bits of this and
talk about it during this video in
addition to the Q&A so if you are
finding me for the first time we do Game
of Thrones every week till season 8 gets
here there'll be giveaway stuff at the
end of the video but don't you just love
how crazy torment is on set the actor
that plays him they're all great people
but the Brotherhood without banners was
probably one of the best parts of all
the behind the scenes Game of Thrones
stuff this season you need to have all
your adrenaline on the maximum so it's
always cool to see Daenerys flying
around to see how they do the Dragons
from a practical standpoint how they do
the whites and these big battles but
really it's when they do these shots
like this like just watching the actors
try to get down all their sword swings
the right way but I know when the
episode actually dropped it was very
divisive for the things that it did not
do namely kill one of these big-name
characters like if Jorah had died that
would have been really heartbreaking in
addition to the dragon so Dan and Dave
talked about how the entire episode
turned around this scene here so if this
hadn't worked it would have been just an
awful episode but I feel like for all
the dragon stuff it actually did work
out the way they wanted it to so all
those extra millions poured literally
poured as concrete into this area to
make this Lake ended up being worth it
we can call torment explaining fights
torment splaining so here we go first
question geez evil ass Khyber needs a
giant dragon glass arrow for his giant
bow is definitely a good idea I feel
like they could benefit from using the
giant scorpion in combination with
dragon glass but there are a number of
ways that he could go the whole thing
about the biggest deaths on the show
like you're talking about Cersei night
king Viserion I think need to be
especially meaningful for the characters
that their most meaningful to so I think
the actual heartbreaking truth of it is
is that Daenerys will be forced to kill
Viserion she'll be forced to kill her
child again think of it as another
version of Cersei being faced with the
choice to kill Joffrey like she said no
matter how much of a monster he was he
was still my son
so Daenerys still thinks of Viserion as
her child when she sees him again with
the blue flame it'll break her heart all
over again
next question Michael Ortiz as what if
the knight King is the third dragon
rider
dragon has three heads yeah there's been
a lot of funny jokes about this going
around since the season was over I do
think that that's the closest we'll get
to the fulfillment of the prophecy
unless you believe the brain can warg an
undead dragon that's really the crackpot
theory that's gaining some steam is like
what did brand could warg the undead
dragon and he becomes the third head of
the dragon you won't walk again but you
will fly although in reality I think
that quote was just about him warding
the Ravens and them flying around next
one cai-you ketsu asks if they hadn't
gone through the wall to get proof of
the dead and lost a dragon how would the
night King make it through the wall well
so this is actually what I think is
gonna happen in the books and it'll
involve the Horn of winter remember
after the night king mark bran and then
it broke the magic seal on the weirwood
people were like oh that's very clearly
going to break the magic seal on the
wall that's how they'll get through but
here's the thing
I feel like Dan and Dave as producers of
a television show said that's not
cinematic enough them just walking
underneath the wall we need to do
something really big and grand so even
though George our Martin told them the
ending of Game of Thrones it's possible
that they embellished the ice dragon
part bringing the wall down I think in
the books it'll be a little more subtle
than that and it'll have something to do
with the Horn of winter next one she is
dead Jim
big Star Trek fan do you think the
dragons are going to die or will there
be a new dynasty I mean would Danny need
a new dragon if all our enemies are dead
well no she wouldn't need a new dragon
but I do think that the two dragons that
are still alive will still be alive at
the end of the season regardless of what
happens to Jon Snow and Daenerys
I feel like there will be new dragon
eggs like it's meant to be a dream of
spring there's the idea that Daenerys
might become pregnant again
she and her family had that deep
connection to the Dragons so the idea
that things would be born a new spring
would come again so that's just why I
think they'll be more dragons in the
future of this timeline even if they
don't address it directly on the TV show
but it depends on if there's a flash
forward at the end of the final episode
next one bitrate asks so if some are
still around could bran work him even if
he's turned well that's actually a big
question it's just like bran working a
dragon George Martin's been asked that
for a long time but never said
definitively I have speculated in the
past the brand's powers will grow as he
learns more about them I think given
enough
he could work summer and his powers flow
from the children of the forest just
like the night Kings so if their powers
come from the same place then he could
probably exert the same level of control
over other beings but I think the idea
is is that the night Kings consciousness
sort of dominates all of the whites that
are risen so bran has to be more
powerful than the night king in order to
break his control on someone next one
Mme asks do you suppose we'll see
Daenerys as a white she's actually one
of the few characters that I don't think
is gonna be turned into a white just
because she's so tied to the Dragons I
think Jon Snow engineers are probably
safe in that respect there are a lot of
theories about Jon Snow becoming the new
night king but it depends on how you
feel about the cycle of Ice and Fire is
the whole idea is to break the wheel
that I think that they're trying to make
it so that there are no more night kings
and that gets into a little bit of book
stuff so I'm just gonna stick to TV show
stuff for now when the actual winds of
winter book drops and we get a bunch
more lore for the White Walkers then we
can talk about that a little bit more
speaking of which next one Thomas asks I
was wondering when you think winds of
winter will be released so this is
actually very dangerous to try and
predict this people have done this for
the last three years I think it'll come
out next year and then just another year
goes by without it happening but I do
think that it will drop before we get
the next season of Game of Thrones that
would put it firmly late 2018 or
anywhere during the middle or early 2019
but it's been a while since Martin has
posted an update chapter he used to do
that pretty regularly he would read
chapters out loud when he would go to
convention appearances but he's stopped
doing that as much so they can spend
more time writing so every once in a
while like a couple times a year we'll
get updates so I'm expecting another one
probably at the end of this year next
one cos Rose asks predictions for the
first episode so I think most of that
episode is gonna be consumed with the
reunions at Winterfell it'll be you know
a lot of great happy moments people are
coming from Daenerys group but the end
of the episode will probably be the
first big night King attack remember
that the last hearth is right up here
close to the wall so our IP umbers they
might just tease that at the end of the
first episode and then use that as like
the first big action set piece of
Episode two but that's what I think is
gonna be the first big knocking attack
but thank you so much for submitting all
these questions these are always a ton
of fun to do and I'll still keep doing
weekly Q&A videos there's a lot of other
TV shows that are getting right
to come back so I might try to do some
Q&A videos for those too in addition to
the Game of Thrones stuff but what's
gonna happen is is I have a Rick and
Morty Q&A that'll post tomorrow there's
a bunch of TV shows that are coming back
next week so there'll be a couple Game
of Thrones videos coming in the next
couple of days but if you have any
special requests just let me know in the
comments I've gotten a lot of requests
for Dragon specific videos but I'll say
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner kill X please private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details what'll happen
is I'll just name a new giveaway winner
when I post my next game of Thrones
video so you haven't seen it in a while
you can click here for my episode 6
video for the actual episode and you can
click here for brand new Rick and Morty
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight